Alex Jones went on his radio show he was
railing against me really saying I stole
his personality I said I stopped
identity really I have you used some of
his credit cards here listen this is
from the Alex Jones Show he goes on air
and constantly lies about me and says
things I never said and says I deserve
to be off the air even lies and says I'm
sending people to Sandy Hook families
like I've never played this audio he has
he plays my shows music he has an
impersonator on it's done so well people
call thinking it's me on they're going
birthday time for the Sandy Hook kids
parody hey on our phone is Alex Jones
with my revenue streams have been cut is
it alright if I plug in for Ward's
product all right I don't do super X
alpha male 3000 it's a mix of baby
powder and lead horse protein ease brown
powder we don't know what's in it why
the leftist media showing videos of
three-year-olds putting money into
strings of fat men wearing wigs shaking
their asses and our children are big I
have to imagine he loves it right or am
i misreading that situation I don't know
Alex I have no idea how his brain works
then he dragged in Mancow to come on his
show and Mitch
yeah because Mancow hates me these two
characters deserve each other
[Music]
and it goes on from there so they're
laughing about dead kids and saying and
then and and they're basically saying
that I'm the one doing it he's the one
making fun of dead kids and then saying
that I'm doing it in my name that's true
scumbag Lee every slammer boost my
friend every slam a boost
don't don't buy into it you shouldn't be
giving them any press the Eagle doesn't
hunt the flea the guy's a mouthpiece of
a deep state he is the problem
Mancow talk to you soon brother brother
all right Alex be strong two brothers he
got bored with man count
take care cow and listen I wasn't
whining about it it's just that they
have stolen my identity I think most
people I would say a hundred percent of
the people no no it's a joke what I was
parroting is this is his real show sandy
hook is a synthetic completely fake with
actors in my view manufactured I
couldn't believe it at first I knew they
had actors there clearly but I thought
they killed some real kids and it just
shows how bold they are that they
clearly used actors no I mean he made it
up I'm not making that [ __ ] up
anyway Alex Jones is on to rebut all of
this via satellite Robin oh yes here we
go here he is if you look at your screen
you can actually solve tyranny well so
does he
from the info wars.com studios it's Alex
Jones Alex I was just trying to
basically say to you that you should be
enjoying this Howard we are the most
demonized most feared most lied about
broadcast in the world you have stolen
my identity you joke about dead kids in
my name meanwhile you're funded by the
corporate system funded by sorrows
funded by the bigger board from
companies funded by the Democratic Party
operatives well you know you do a lot of
talking and everything but no one even
hears you anymore because they've taken
you off of every station we have been
taken off because people like you push
for democratic trakone Ian's censorship
you take the marching orders you
constantly spread out out of context
lies its unified front of fraud you and
your impersonator who comes on it says
birthday time for the Sandy Hook kids
you say things I never said on the air
like what like you say people come to me
I get death threats they say you say
Sandy Hook did it happen I say that's
what Howard Stern said I said and I
didn't even say it it's an impersonator
saying I said it as me on the show now I
got to tell you something when you talk
you talk so fast I don't even know
what's going on how are you making a
living anymore I mean what about your
products I have a lot of product listen
there is no lead in our products there's
no concrete not much asbestos they're
all now fresh herbs in these products
right yeah what is this
yes alpha-male fusion discover the power
of ancient medicine it's a mixture of
b-vitamins blackbolt gonna promote your
eyes tight give you have your breathing
louder hearing stronger kegels
you're gonna Leakey you're gonna love it
Wow well I guess I'm doing you a favor
you should thank me at least I get your
products out yeah absolutely
hold on once I thought this would happen
Howard but I'm getting a call right now
Howard Stern is on my phone should I
pick up go ahead I would actually be
honored all right let's hear what he has
to say hello Howard hey no I'm drinking
my coffee and being a degenerate
globalist scumbag Wow so I'm glad you
admit that Howard by the way what are
you doing on your show this week Howard
would you like to let us know
well sure ring a NAMBLA fundraiser and
then joking about dead kids and
spreading lies about you for four hours
Wow so glad you're honest our and I'll
definitely be tuning into your show
today no I got to go to Bohemian Grove
and do some Luciferian rituals we'll see
everybody tomorrow which Stern wrap-up
show starts live two hours from now
there you go Howard Stern well Alex you
sure got me back I got to admit by bowl
oh that's fair play I mean I make fun of
your show and you know I know well you
put together all right well anyway glad
we spoke I guess we made some sense here
and we we came together and talked at
least we did that right the fire of
Liberty will not be not doubt it so Wars
calm free Rogers down for Wars calm
there he goes goodbye later love that